he has a speech about kindness and love
even though he literally slapped the
taste out of somebody's mouth if you
look that [ __ ] up in the dictionary
slapping the taste out of somebody's
mouth it's a picture of will's slapping
chris rock in the [ __ ] face he turned
into the chris pebbles dude
and then there's the other side where
for me i actually applaud chris rock
more yeah because of how controlled he
was right absolutely and even in five
four three
two
one hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast
hi what the [ __ ] is with your face
i am your host david so
and we have ed park the other one
today it's been a minute man it has man
we're in a new podcast studio yes
feeling good refining it making it look
better trying to make sure that people
understand that their patreon money is
actually going to use it's definitely an
upgrade from the last spot for you yeah
so we have a patreon and obviously i
haven't really posted it it's funny
because when i had the patreon
originally
a lot of the stuff was like me dming
people like oh what content do you want
to see and
90 of the people on there were like oh
we're just supporting you so it doesn't
matter you don't really have to post
anything yeah i'm like oh okay um
cool yeah
i guess i just take the money then thank
you well it's not really going to me
it's going into this you know upgrading
the space so like i want people think
i'm running away with their money like
obviously i'm not buying new clothes and
[ __ ] this is all going into this better
space and kind of making it a lot just a
lot more accessible because originally
we were going to have it outside of the
house but instead i just got a new place
yeah just with a separate area which was
[ __ ] hard to find by the way yeah but
look at this now there's [ __ ]
multiple cameras yeah exactly you got
the two camera system going uh
everything looks nice and polished and
elegant in here you know you got you got
that you got that mood in here man i
know you got that podcast
[Laughter]
let me unzip record
asmr zipper
exactly do you know what i've been
watching um so i have trouble sleeping
but asmr [ __ ] is the stuff that helps me
sleep really well really that and uh
edibles but that
it has to be together yeah i've been
watching this one channel i don't know
what her name is i don't even think
she's japanese but she does speak
japanese or she's a hapa okay but it's
her getting pampered
she's genius by the way yeah she makes a
living by recording herself getting
pampered by who by these japanese people
who that have a very specific modality
in terms of whether it's scalp massage
body massage hand massage um
the uh
gua shu gua shao the uh the stone thing
no no
i don't know what it's called either of
me but have you seen um chinese people
where they use like a jade stone and
they'll do it for wrinkles and um i've
seen that little thing that looks like a
dildo with the two balls at the end okay
that girl's always rubbing on their face
bro when i first saw that i thought it
was a dildo at the shop i remember like
my ex was looking at it and i'm like yo
they just straight up got dildos on this
split it's like for your face like you
tell this guy to [ __ ] leave already
he's already said balls and dildo
that's what i thought it was though i
mean the shape of it because it has like
this long [ __ ] thing and then the two
balls at the end yeah it's supposed to
um like tighten your skin and massage it
yeah you're supposed to throw it into
like a freezer to have it cold first
also make you have an orgasm no i don't
know about that so let's drink your
pores or some [ __ ] look at this guy this
is why you're not a lot of nice places
you piece of [ __ ] but we had um
oh yeah so this lady so she started
going into this thing i'll maybe i'll
leave a link in the bottom of the uh of
the video if you guys see it but
she
i think she got popular from doing
japanese scalp massages so it's like
japanese scalp detoxes but the lady is
telling you what she's doing in japanese
kind of in a very you know japanese
people speak
but that's what it sounds like to me
yeah and she's doing her [ __ ] and she's
getting scalp massage but she created
this whole youtube channel which gets
like hundreds of thousands of views of
her just getting pampered how [ __ ]
genius is that man
so she's doing this out in public or she
has these people come to her home no she
does it at the at the spot and so she's
there getting her scalp massage and it's
the most relaxing [ __ ] i've ever seen i
didn't know that you could specialize in
hand massages
bro there's something for everybody in
every interest on the online now dude
literally japanese people they know how
to focus on one thing really really well
yeah like this lady is the scout massage
goddess
[Laughter]
she'll do her [ __ ] for an hour wait wait
wait so she gives scalp massages as well
no no she's receiving she's receiving it
she's only getting pampered okay it's
just sweet sweet little maybe like half
a asian girl that gets it done but it
helps me fall asleep what kind of [ __ ]
is that man you get comfort from
watching somebody else get comfort yeah
it's like when somebody gets slapped at
the oscars
let me tell you something right now i
have never seen so many [ __ ] people
online yeah whip out a tux from senior
prom just so they could do a [ __ ]
sketch it was crazy how fast it was
though that happened and i saw every
[ __ ] account that i follow somehow
managed to gather 13 people and do a
sketch that's what i'm saying like i
think one of the quickest ones within 10
minutes you know and yeah like i i saw
the one where like you know the dude's
looking at the photo it's not that bad
yeah
he slapped the [ __ ] at you
when i saw that [ __ ] the first thing i
thought was holy [ __ ] if somebody screen
grabs this it's gonna look like that
batman comic book slap
exactly and then literally five minutes
later yeah you did it yep i'm like holy
[ __ ] he slapped the [ __ ] out of [ __ ]
cr everybody hates chris
everybody loves will
but everybody hates chris dude life
imitates art you know everybody hates
chris that is literally the name of his
show that he had the sitcom and it's a
hundred percent true they're actually
friends i know that's the crazy [ __ ] and
and look man i think it caught everybody
off guard because it was like oh that
had to be scripted that had to be staged
right but then it's like
you heard that sound you know that that
hand to face contact sound you know what
was crazy you could tell by their
personal relationship how much trust
that chris rock had with will smith
right because he didn't expect to get
slapped right right because everybody
knows too by the way by the way i
shouldn't even have to preface who chris
rock is but
whoa
bro
[Laughter]
is a comedic legend yeah right in the
likes of dave chappelle and everything
else
um it's weird when i heard the
conversation because
i am in between everything i'm like
straight right down the middle yeah i
don't condone it but i understand it
that's how i feel about this right so uh
for those of you who don't know what's
going on you probably don't have a
television or you don't own a computer
been living under a [ __ ] rocker so
the oscars were was the other day and
when this comes out it's going to be
four or five days ago
uh
will so chris rock is presenting for the
oscars you know presenting awards or
whatever what not for the documentary
yes yeah the documentary documentary and
uh if you've seen chris rock at at the
oscars he doesn't pull punches yeah he
does a lot of like
quote-unquote controversial jokes uh for
example i think in one of the oscars he
did like an asian joke with apple and a
bunch of kids yeah yeah yeah yeah those
kids in the suits or tuxedos yeah a lot
of asian people were upset i personally
wasn't yeah i didn't yeah i didn't
really mind it but hey you know if
you're offended by it you're allowed to
be offended by it whatever you little
you [ __ ] [ __ ] maybe you should use a
jade ball
but um he
goes up and you know he starts doing his
little roast he'll start roasting a few
people here and there and then when it
comes to jada pink and smith he says
that she's going for the royal gi chain
too yeah because she has a bald head
yeah now
i'm not sure if chris rock knew this
because i personally didn't know this
alopecia but she has alopecia which is
autoimmune disease which causes you to
lose hair yeah the only reason why i
know uh about alopecia is because i
[ __ ] up once
so let me tell you this
oh no so my best friend was going out
with the girl at the time and this is
during the time that he was going into
medical school
and i she knew that she knows that i
grew up in a black beauty supply store
and there used to be this like stand-up
bit then whenever i would do
uh i would specifically open up let's
say if i did i don't know like a
chocolate sundae it's that's like la's
version of but if i did a multi-uh
multi-ethnic crowd and a majority was
black i would just open up with like
saying like listen i know every [ __ ]
girl here i know every every i know
where you got every single piece on your
head and i would go off like naming like
hair colors weaves whatever and it's
always on point because that's what i
did 24 7 at the time
so i was just talking like yeah man i
could tell when a girl's hair isn't real
that [ __ ] and you know was you know
making jokes everybody's laughing
and i looked over at her
and then
i realized that she had a hairpiece on
yeah right but it looked a little and i
looked at her eyebrows and looked like
she didn't have any hair there yeah
and
and after it's all said and done
afterwards my uh my friend came up to me
it's like bro my girl got alopecia bro
and i'm like
[ __ ]
i knew her [ __ ] looked funny yeah but i
did not know that she had alopecia did
she have kind of like a weird reaction
she didn't have a weird reaction and she
wasn't even mad okay because she never
that's a good good good good because she
never she never told me yeah you know
yeah and i i guess like at that point
yeah she just got diagnosed with it yeah
but you know afterwards like she mad
because i want to apologize to her she
goes dude she's not mad at all like she
just i'm just letting you know because i
was dying laughing on the inside because
you're over here making jokes and this
girl's over here like this [ __ ]
don't even know yeah cuz she was really
cool yeah but when i thought about that
[ __ ] i was wondering if chris rock knew
that she had alopecia it seems like he
didn't know but i mean here's the thing
man there's a lot to [ __ ] unpack with
this situation because
first of all people are making it sound
like [ __ ] alopecia is like the worst
type of cancer or something in the world
i i read some ridiculous two people
online are so [ __ ] dumb
if somebody wrote they go oh how would
wouldn't you want to protect your
woman's honor if she had cancer she
doesn't have cancer she has something
that causes her hair to fall out yeah
health-wise she's in perfect condition
exactly also too yeah she's rich and
she's fine as [ __ ] exactly
to the point where i didn't know that
she had alopecia i thought she was just
doing this yeah i thought that's what
everybody thought everybody just thought
you know she looks good in a bald cut so
she's just doing it bro that's all i
thought i was like damn dude i didn't
think anything of it i never thought hmm
i wonder why jada pinkett smith shaved
her head it's just one of those things
where it's like oh okay i guess that's
her new do now you know then she looks
good in it yeah and the story i thought
it was also hilarious too that when this
[ __ ] happened that lupita nyong'o was
next to her and she was also bald
i was like
what's going on [ __ ] chris wrong
about to make a joke about her too yeah
but you know that's the thing man like
the the joke bad taste sure we could say
it's in bad taste but
you know will being will like
hugely out of character first of all
right we we never seen will do anything
remote actually i'm not going to say
remotely close because there wasn't that
slap that [ __ ] yeah one report yeah one
report see that's the first thing i
thought of when i saw the clip i was
like well this ain't well's first time
it ain't his first rodeo just
philadelphia
exactly
um but you know because it was so
outlandish of an act like i was like for
sure this had to be staged but then you
know he issued an apology earlier today
so it seems like we could say for the
most part it seems real right
the the odd thing about this is like so
the reason why it's so hard to unpack
him the reason why i'm right in the
middle right it's because
there's a few things number one
i was talking to this uh talking about
the subject with rick is like i was so
upset that we'll slap chris rock because
now
that is gonna be the standard for men
across the world it's like now we all
got to stand the [ __ ] because he's so
influential now we have to go around
slapping the [ __ ] out of people because
this guy but
it's it's weird because i'd say this i'm
only saying this from a position to
somebody who wasn't in will smith's
position right number one
i could say right now that this is the
solution that i would do
however i wasn't there and i and i know
how i am when i get hot-headed i'm
pretty sure i probably wouldn't have
done the same i could only hope that i
would do this yeah if they had a
personal relationship right it would
have been great if will smith waited
received his award afterwards and
slapped him backstage or something
something like hey yeah you know jada
has alopecia you know the [ __ ] that
she's been going through yeah for you to
make a joke at her expense and at my
expense in front of this [ __ ] crowd
when you know when we're homies that's
[ __ ] up well let me ask you this then
where was that where was that same
energy for august all cena then you know
what i'm saying
where was that energy
well here's the thing right yeah
i think will smith has been put into
this position where he's always mr nice
guy right yeah he always has to let
things roll off his shoulder or whatever
and he's always somebody who's very
prophetic and likes to give you know
advice about kindness and love yeah but
the problem with that is that even for
somebody like him
though i don't believe he gets a lot of
negative comments i'm pretty sure the
stuff that he does read that gets to his
ear probably starts to eat him up
specifically about his family right the
only issue that i have with that is that
the stuff that people have said about
will and his family it's the stuff that
jada pinkett smith on her red table talk
has allowed for people to say because
she has discussed it openly with people
right so they're first first because
like just to start this off
with will smith
he started being called like a cuck and
everything else and i heard these
comments here and there you know
because of the august all-star thing
yeah and that's not something that he
put out into the public that's something
that his wife did yeah where she was
calling it an what an entanglement an
entanglement and basically you suck
somebody else's dick who by the way jada
you stated himself yourself that he was
mentally unstable and to be honest with
you what that looks like is you kind of
took advantage of this dude
right yeah so you know it's it's a
little bit of both so that and he's
really young yes really [ __ ] yeah i
think it was like 21 when this happened
yeah he was like 21 or something so it's
like yeah technically he's an adult by
by but she did take advantage of it yeah
but he's still a kid when it comes to
the grand scheme of things but you know
they're probably going to have to do a
red table talk with this because you're
going to need some healing
another entanglement here yeah man and
that's that's the weird thing so that's
how i would have dealt with that
situation in in a in a perfect world
yeah my lovely genius farts let's keep
this podcast sponsored and going by
checking out the lost debate
that's where the lost debate steps in my
friends in your life because do you feel
like you're living in a media bubble
like it's harder than ever to find views
that challenge your own
lost debates here for you my friends we
have the host ravi gupta corey bradford
and ricky schlott my friends giving you
the best they come from across the
political island from different
generations but come together for
debates that sound less like crossfire
more like discussions between real
people because we hate this news that
keeps getting biased and twisted and
turned without real conversations and
real information well guess what that's
where the lost debate comes in man we're
talking about diversity of beliefs and
perspectives what's good homie join the
conversation check out the lost debate
today new episodes drop tuesday and
thursdays find the lost debate on
youtube apple podcast spotify or
wherever you get your shows
but the funny thing if i'm not sure if
you caught this but when he made the
joke will was laughing i know he laughed
and then it was
i think he looked at jada and she kind
of like rolled her eyes like this
oh what would tupac do yeah in this
situation i just pictured will just
going
yeah oh jade is mad yeah
oh yeah
because i've definitely done that too
where like recently i talked about this
on the podcast with the with the last
place i was living at yeah i wasn't that
upset until marielle told me that she
disrespected mariel and then i started
getting angry
but here's the thing though man it's
like
will isn't some new kid on the block
when it comes to hollywood man he's
been a mainstay in the hollywood forum
for a long long time he's gone through
all the ups and downs of whatever
hollywood has to throw at him and the
life right he's rich he's famous he's
good looking his kids are talented you
know he has a beautiful wife he's pretty
much on top of the world it's like dude
you can take a little bit of jabs coming
your way especially in a setting like
that right it ain't like it's at a
comedy club it's at an award show and
you might win your first [ __ ] oscar
tonight
but
he for some whatever reason reacted the
way he did and maybe i don't know man it
was just the wrong thing to say at the
right time and it triggered him there's
something else because you usually see
him very composed yeah i'm pretty sure
so there's some other [ __ ] that a lot of
people don't know about there has to be
there has to be in his personal
relationship with his wife yeah his
family stuff and that's that's the only
reason i'm saying that is because this
kind of experience comes with age i
think when you're younger you look at
that and it's easy just to you know go
on twitter and instagram and point
fingers and say he shouldn't have done
that but at the same time i'm not
excusing the [ __ ] behavior right but
it's very out of character for somebody
like him from what we've seen in public
right i don't i never would have
expected that from will smith here's the
thing though here's the thing now we can
safely say so far he's gotten a pretty
big pass right because he was allowed to
stay he was allowed to get the award he
was allowed to go basically unlimited
with his speech they didn't cap him i
think he spoke like five minutes in his
acceptance speech
now
again what you said earlier everybody
hates chris but everybody loves will
do you think he gets a pass because it's
imagine
somebody
that
let's say has a history with violence
and beating chris brown let's say he did
that
chris rock made a joke about i don't
know rihanna back in the day and chris
brown got up there and slapped the [ __ ]
out of chris rock you think he would
have got that pass
i don't think so well chris brown
wouldn't because chris brown is used to
beating up women so
chris brown is you know that boy
anybody with a different chromosome
that's true that's true but you know
what i mean if it was somebody where
like yeah there was there was
conversations too where people were like
he only did that because that's chris
rock but let's see him do that to like
jason mamoa right right there's that
aspect too but it's like i still think
he would have slapped the [ __ ] at jason
mama though just because at that point i
think like will smith he looks like he
was fed up yeah he was triggered by
something man people were must have been
jabbing at him hard in his personal
circle later not just
i think in like outside circle stuff i'm
pretty sure it's like people around in
his vicinity that have been talking
about him yeah that probably [ __ ] him
up so bad yeah
you know it's hard to say all we can do
is speculate on
what might have been going on behind the
scenes that we didn't see that
basically it was it was the straw that
broke the camel's back um but here's the
thing too is that like it was so jarring
for something like that to happen and
then he gets his acceptance speech and
he's talking about god is calling on him
to be a vessel of love and he i'm like
that's
yeah i was like yo man you just slapped
the [ __ ] out of a guy and millions and
millions of people saw it live and this
[ __ ] was not fake and then he didn't
apologize to chris there he apologized
to his fellow nominees into the academy
he didn't feel like he should that's why
he was like yeah you deserve that and
then and then the aftermath today was
the academy came out and made a
statement they said we don't condone
violence but they didn't call will out
by name
they just kind of weaved around it and
said oh and then they said we're going
to look open a formal investigation to
the incident what do you mean a formal
investigation
millions of
people what are
i like how the japanese translation was
so calm still
especially when will is out there saying
keep my wife's name out your [ __ ]
mouth
and he looked pissed so so the slap to
me initially seemed fake but when i saw
him say what he said i was like oh [ __ ]
yeah this motherfucker's really mad
right now so chris rock issued an
apology too oh he did yeah so i did not
know that so as a comedian it can be
difficult to understand which lines are
to be crossed and which ones aren't last
night i crossed a line that i shouldn't
have and paid the enormous price of my
reputation and as a renowned comedian
comedy is never about poking fun at or
making light of people with major
ordeals happenings in their lives
comedy's about using real life
circumstances to create laughter and
bring light to an otherwise dark world
you might agree with that said i
sincerely apologize to my friends jada
pinkett smith will smith and the rest of
the smith family for the disrespect and
disregard i displayed which was
unfortunately broadcast for the world to
see i hope that with time forgiveness
can come of the situation and we can all
be better more considerate uh people in
the end chris rock hey kudos to
[ __ ] chris rock because
honestly man he is a champion of
professionalism dude
carried on yeah he got slapped was so
[ __ ] dope it's like he did not miss a
beat bro yeah i was like man you could
not honestly have handled that any
better and i think afterwards too
everybody was just kind of on team chris
you know yeah i was just like dude
you were [ __ ]
professional through and through it
throughout the whole thing um i can't
personally imagine somebody slapping the
[ __ ] out of me and me not throwing hands
right on me
he literally
did he just continued on yeah that was
pretty [ __ ] amazing but
wow
yeah will smith just slap the [ __ ] out
of me
you know
i will say this though
i personally didn't like his joke
because of that right so
because of what the alopecia well
because the joke that he made is left
for a roast like he said like this is
something that she is that's wrecking
her um i didn't know that per se but i'm
pretty sure because if they are friends
he probably knows that so if he did know
that that's probably why will was even
more mad because that's somebody that's
in his personal circle that did that
[ __ ] yeah so
that's the type of joke in a roast that
it's it's actually a pretty soft
lob to be honest with you it is but i
think it's more
offensive because that person's in a
circle because that person knows about
what his what his wife is going through
and they're actual friends yeah for him
to do that on that public platform and
once again it's not a joke making it's
not a crass or harsh joke making an
observation about something that's going
on in life it's just him saying
you're bald yeah you have alabama well
context matters right in this situation
then like to joke stand alone by itself
it's whatever yeah it's super weird it's
very light yeah but because there's the
personal aspect to that joke and yeah
maybe chris rock did know since he
issued an apology and he
crossed that line obviously that he's
saying he shouldn't have crossed um but
you know the whole thing
i mean chris rock created an instant
like
uh oscar's moment without even knowing
he was gonna be a part of it bro that is
the best moment in any oscar i bet by
the way i don't ever watch oscars
anymore yeah i don't give a [ __ ] about
the oscars i literally do not [ __ ]
care the oscars to me is ass yeah it is
it's pretty bad it's just a bunch of
rich people coming together to tell
people that they're rich and artsy for
doing the [ __ ] that they're doing i
could give a [ __ ] less you know who's
the biggest loser in in this whole
incident though was quest love because
he was the guy who won the award for the
documentary and nobody cared nobody
cared i just thought about that right
now i don't know what the award was yes
it was
quest love one
everybody was just [ __ ] on their
phones and talking about what had just
happened so he's like giving his
acceptance speech but he didn't get an
apology from anybody i know
well let's read will's apology
quest love right here just drumming in
the corner
he's like all right guys well yeah so i
did win an award here so i won an award
who the [ __ ] is this question did you
just see what happened quiz come on man
sit your ass down get the [ __ ] off the
stage man this is the real documentary
violence in all of its forms is
poisonous and destructive my behavior at
last night's academy awards was
unacceptable and inexcusable jokes at my
expense are a part of the job but a joke
about jada's medical condition was too
much for me to bear and i reacted
emotionally i would like to publicly
apologize to you chris i was out of line
and i was wrong i'm embarrassed and my
actions were not indicative of the man i
want to be there's no place for violence
in a world of love and kindness
i don't know the world's full of love
and kindness i'm pretty sure you know
what's going on in ukraine and russia
i would also like to apologize to the
academy the producers of the show
all the attendees and everyone watching
around the world i would like to
apologize to the williams family and my
king richard family i deeply regret that
my behavior has stained what has been an
otherwise gorgeous journey for all of us
i am a work in progress sincerely will
you know i think for you you apologize
to chris yeah he did yeah yeah
he omitted him in the apology again no
but like for me
the thing that i took away from this the
biggest thing that i took away from it
is just like how warped the world of
hollywood and celebrity life really is
because as soon as that [ __ ] had
happened i don't know if you saw these
um behind the scenes clips you saw like
denzel going to will to comfort him um
bradley cooper went to go and comfort
him um
tyler parried it
and then afterwards like you know he
goes on to get a speech he's applauded
there's a standing ovation people
literally acting like nothing just
[ __ ] happened like
i think because they probably
emotionally agreed
with will for what he did because they
love will because will is will i think
that's why he got such a pass with it
but like cause he's hollywood lover boy
yeah exactly exactly but but also just
like
that i just pictured myself slapping the
[ __ ] out of somebody up there and
everybody starts booing me and throwing
tomatoes yeah exactly well that but
that's what i mean though it's like
their level of elite
their elite status the power and fame
that they have just
i don't know man it sets a very weird
precedent for like normal folks you know
because like you said now
if that something like that happens the
standard is oh i gotta slap a
[ __ ] somebody just calls mario
[ __ ] fat and then she's like well
well
what are you gonna do about it
might come up and slap this guy there's
consequences i'm gonna go to jail but
yeah man it's just so [ __ ] like
warped it just felt like it's own world
and we're just outside looking in of
like oh well there's definitely
favoritism and a bias right yeah
absolutely in that situation when i
looked at it right because like you said
everybody's applauding will for what he
did you know in terms of you know
receiving his oscar yeah yeah yeah and
he has a speech about kindness and love
even though he literally slapped the
taste out of somebody's mouth if you
look that [ __ ] up in the dictionary
slapping the taste out of somebody's
mouth it's a picture of will's slapping
chris rock in the [ __ ] face he turned
into chris pebbles dude
just obliterated him
and then
and then there's the other side where
for me i actually applaud chris rock
more yeah because of how controlled he
was right absolutely and even though i
once again i disagree with the the
timing and the place of his joke for me
if he made that joke inside of a comedy
club i think i'm okay with it because
that's comedy world everybody can
[ __ ] get it you stepped into this
world yeah it's the oscars you're in
their arena exactly this is a little
different i think you do but ricky
gervais man this guy
[ __ ] roasts the [ __ ] out of people so
hard 100 but like what chris rock said
it was what he did was in poor taste
because ricky gervais was pointing out
jokes about a system of people you think
that they're special and right better
than other people
but that's that's exactly what i'm
alluding to right now that point that's
what it felt like i was looking at it's
like for sure you know these guys are
just living in a different world and
normal things uh if in a normal world
where normal people knew
normal people would do something like
that the consequences would be far
greater which is something completely
different but yet instead we're seeing
the complete opposite of this dude
getting applauded people getting
emotional like oh my god he you know
he's he's so sick he's standing here
because all of us get bullied and he's
finally stood up to a bully
i personally i don't know if i really
saw it like that i like i said i'm in
the fence about a lot of things because
i feel like i would definitely defend
somebody that i love that's going
through a lot of [ __ ] absolutely but the
way he went about it and then the
purpose of it i i don't think it was
smart at all yeah and it was a little
for me it was unwarranted because chris
rock is a comedian and he's going to
make jokes right
you coming up and slapping the [ __ ] out
of somebody at a public forum like that
number one i don't think it makes him
look that good right it doesn't make him
look like i don't know quote unquote
more of a man no or something right
absolutely not if anything else it makes
you look weak because you can't control
your emotions and confront somebody
personally i think it's safe to say he
probably lost a lot of fans because of
that moment yeah i mean he's gonna be
fine yeah well he is of course yeah he's
will smith no matter what but i'm saying
it's like the infallible will smith
finally showed a [ __ ] in his armor yeah
and people were like whoa man what the
[ __ ] was that you [ __ ] i mean i see
plenty of chinks in uh will's armor dude
i mean the guy [ __ ] literally added
in
with the lady who had an entanglement
and he just just sat there and took it
you know
yeah i'm not blaming the guy but it was
a little i think that that whole
debacle with the red table talk of her
talking about his entanglement yeah and
that whole [ __ ] was like it didn't make
me lose respect for him but i'm thinking
that not everything has to be public
guys no and exactly i don't think i
don't think will exactly volunteered
himself for that situation
when she said entanglement i saw will's
face and it was the same face he was
making at chris rock when he told him to
keep jada's name out of his [ __ ]
mouth i was like oh that's the face i
saw at the tabletop
when jada was telling you about the
entanglement yeah he was pretty upset
yeah it was ah just overall really
[ __ ] weird situation um i didn't know
what to make of it when it initially
happened but yeah clearly we come to
find out if [ __ ] was real wasn't
scripted because yeah i was kind of
looking at what might be the angle here
um what what is there to gain if this is
fake right because you really can't put
anything past hollywood in terms of when
it comes to pr it's free for all right
people have fake relationships for pr
purposes people have like kids for pr
purpose so you know an incident like
this can happen from a pr stunt
standpoint but i was like who wins from
this though the academies yeah okay they
win but will doesn't really win here
you know and i will say this to you know
just to point out a point that will was
saying about his situation is that
though he wasn't saying it directly i
i'm always clear about this how a lot of
people forget especially because
entertainment has evolved into this
crazy monster now yeah it's not just you
get to see somebody on tv and film now
is you see them on instagram facebook
youtube everywhere constantly 24 [ __ ]
seven then
people kind of feel like
these people who are in the limelight
are now their possessions we actually
are everything you do we are owed so
he wasn't he didn't say it outright but
people are forgetting about these people
being people they're human beings they
have emotions they have flaws they're
going to [ __ ] up some people are albeit
very much better at hiding it than
others i'm never surprised like here's
one of the things too
every time here's something that you
guys may or may not know right
if you guys ever read an article let's
say about um
somebody saying uh there was a there was
an actor he
he was he didn't show up on a second
season of a show and they're like why
he's such a big part of the show and
like oh they didn't pay him enough and
that's why they didn't come back on so
because i've been in this industry for
quite a bit you know the reason why that
happens
the reason why they got a [ __ ] offer is
because they don't want to work with you
it's their way of slightly like saying
like you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] you were
hard to work with you complained you
were troublesome or your acting was
[ __ ] terrible so instead of just
saying hey we're just you know having
that serious conversation and just
letting them go and having them go on a
tear they just give them a
slightly offensive offer and they go no
i'm not going to take that i'm better
than this exactly i quit it's the it's
the version of it's not you it's me
exactly
100
but a lot of people don't know in this
industry and i know this too because i'm
not exactly what you call the most liked
person is that people will hire somebody
just like a job a lot of the times when
you guys get jobs outside of
entertainment people who are
entertainers what's what's the thing you
guys find out that your degrees don't
mean [ __ ] um where you graduate never
meant [ __ ] is in the interview do they
like you do they want to work with you
and see you every day that's the same
[ __ ] for what you see in hollywood if i
have to be on set as a director cast
crew other members they have to be
around an [ __ ] of a human being and
you're [ __ ] difficult guess what they
don't want to be around you
but this is this is what it is people
are human beings so like i've seen
multiple times where these people are
they don't come for a second season
guess what i just ask around here and
there i'm like why they won't say it
outright but they're like this person's
kind of a [ __ ] [ __ ] it's so hard
to deal with them yeah and that's why it
was just a nightmare they're like i'm
not gonna personally say it because
they're not in you know in charge of
hiring them but people know about this
word gets around and if you see those
same people they never ever get picked
up for another show for a very long time
and the reason why is because you're a
[ __ ] dick
you know yeah
but like
yeah people do forget that celebrities
are human beings and when i see like
celebrities mess up i'm just like it's
just
it's a matter of time honestly you know
you can only take someone like okay
granted they are living a life that's
completely different to most people's
lives and we can't even fathom what it's
like to live their life but like you
said there is still the human element of
it they do have feelings they do have
thoughts and look no human is really
designed to live the life of a celebrity
like some of these mega celebrities to
be like to receive that type of
adulation fame wealth like in in you
know handed to you by the plateful right
it's gonna [ __ ] a person's mind up in
some way but like you said again some
people are just better at hiding it some
people are just better at putting on
that mask and that face let me ask you
let's say you were
out and about in the excretes yeah and
then somebody disrespects your lady yeah
what do you do
i mean i've i've definitely you know
gotten into some altercations because
something something like some guy was
just like your [ __ ] lady has alopecia
i don't know why i have to say yeah
how do you know that
i don't even know you like that excuse
me sir no i mean yeah i think defending
you know your partner's honor is very
important and
if um
it depends when you're asking me this
question now or when i was younger now
now okay yeah now i think i'm a lot more
mature and a lot more level-headed so
resorting to violence wouldn't be the
first thing i would be like there would
definitely be confrontation like yo you
need to watch what the [ __ ] you're
saying but then from there if it
escalates then yeah we might we might
have to you know throw some hands but i
would just ask like what did she say to
you exactly
because this one [ __ ] troublesome
yeah what did she say
she's what what did she do yeah did she
start this [ __ ] like what happened yeah
like i don't know like i just don't
generally like
fighting yeah like most of the time like
i i like 99.9 i'll walk away unless i
absolutely
have to right because i'd rather just
stay alive yeah because you know you
don't know people are [ __ ] crazy
obviously i'm [ __ ] in l.a man yeah
people can just start shooting you they
have knives or whatever if it's a
stranger out in public i'm gonna walk
away it doesn't matter if i look like a
[ __ ] or a [ __ ] or whatever
um if i'm walking away and they're still
coming at me then obviously i have to do
something okay but what if it's not an
insult and instead they're hollering at
your girl with you right there are you
offended by that that's kind of tired
you feel good about it then like [ __ ] so
yeah that's right hollering hollering at
uh somebody that i'm with doesn't affect
me because it's this if if it makes them
feel uncomfortable then i will allow
them to stand up for themselves first
because nobody needs a guy to walk in
and be their knight in striming armor if
they don't need it right yeah and most
women that i've been with they've been
able to handle themselves they don't
need my [ __ ] dumb ass to walk in and
be like hey buddy
what's going on what did you
no don't i don't think so man i think
most women are capable of at least
defending themselves verbally at that
point and other girls probably will
whoop another dude's ass um i i don't
think i would care about that stuff like
if a guy like
tried to hit mariel that'd be different
oh yeah i mean once you're talking about
like physical attacks that's a
completely different story listen i walk
around with a little bag on me and
inside that bag is a little switch blade
why you keep holding that thing anyway
i don't know but this is not the
switchblade this is the extra
well you could do some damage with that
too [ __ ] poke somebody in the eye with
that dog i would literally
uh this is hypothetical in cases every
year that guys he said i would literally
but it's hypothetical i would
hypothetically literally
gut somebody open like a [ __ ] fish
and let them rot and die in the middle
of the [ __ ] street for what if
somebody struck mariel um absolutely
yeah yeah yeah if it's like an insult
it's like all right buddy come on you
know we will probably just walk away
because liv you know just to live
another day yeah no that's the smartest
thing to do that's the most mature thing
to do it's not worth it you know no
matter what it is that they're saying
if they're like if they have some screws
loose enough for them to yell
profanities or insults you know randomly
it's just like
you know what you're not even [ __ ]
worth the time but
it depends on what day and what time
just like will it might just hit me the
wrong way on the wrong day you know and
i'm like what the [ __ ] you just said i
know
i've had those moments i've had those
moments like i remember bro one time my
friend um we were at a bar uh and this
isn't even like my partner this is just
you know a homie of mine right
he had gotten surgery on his leg so he
was on crutches
and then this uh this dude like was kind
of like clowning him
and and like kind of bumped his shoulder
completely uncalled for shoulder bump
and i and i took major offense to that
so like you know i [ __ ] put my hands
on him like yo what the [ __ ] you doing
man
like you don't see this dude got [ __ ]
crutches man you just had surgery what
the [ __ ] your problem you got a
problem do it with me then right
he's like oh no just plain man i just
i was like nah you're not [ __ ]
playing man the dude is on [ __ ]
crutches yeah that's not that's not no
way to play you know yeah but dude was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] obviously because once it
got real he was like oh i'm just playing
you know yeah he's having fun weren't
you everybody everybody loves that that
thing it's that i'm just playing live
yeah it's the most obnoxious i see
that's what i'm saying it's like those
were those are one of those moments
where it just struck me the wrong way
and it really [ __ ] bothered me where
i was like i'm going to step in and i'm
going to do something cause like my
friend was just just kind of like
shrugging it off like whatever
i'm like [ __ ] you i'ma protect your
honor bro
[ __ ] this guy
it's so weird man like i can't even
imagine doing
any type of like aggressive well i mean
that's not true i guess because just
that is not true at all i don't know
you got some partial ambitions you're
right
whatever man all right i'm saying you
have chosen chaos many times my friends
however i choose i try not to the most
i have really bad luck with people i i
really really [ __ ] do like that dude
at [ __ ] the gym exactly i don't know
what the chances are that a [ __ ]
crazed person was gonna just start
swinging at me yeah that [ __ ] sucked
yeah you have to realize how much i
dislike fighting to the point it's not
like i walked around hyped i took i took
a nap in my car after for like two hours
you know i'm so tired i was like oh this
is exhausting
the adrenaline rush was too much i need
a nap dude [ __ ] i went to um oh
smoking grooves quest love was there
plus love was there uh nas which
basically anna's genie aiko janae aiko
a bunch of people were there and then i
was supposed to meet up uh bart geo our
buddy silent mike my buddy anthony and
his girl
i had to go to a birthday party before
so i was like hey
gio dropped off my ticket i was like i'm
gonna see you all there
um i went to a birthday party before two
of my friends uh were going to go to the
smoking groups concert so i was like
okay this is what we're gonna do we're
gonna go to this birthday party
uh and then from the birthday party
we're both gonna dip
and then we're gonna head out and then
we'll just go to the smoking groups
concert i have a bunch of friends there
oh sorry
the reason why i'm laughing
is because you [ __ ] roasted your boy
aunt about
his pursuit
[Laughter]
when you said
hold on we're going to sidetrack real
quick because we have to talk about this
[ __ ] not listen i was like why you got
to do it like that bro let me let me
explain let me explain let me explain my
thought process before we continue this
oh [ __ ] i am a true believer in helping
my friends out
and i love those helping them out let me
tell you something
so
a few weeks a couple weeks ago maybe i
put up the story it's our lovely friend
ann and christina i love this kind of
death he's the homie however he has been
doing something really stupid lately
and he had this [ __ ] refuses to
tailor his suits he looks like he raided
his daddy's closet and he walks around
oh [ __ ] in this suit that clearly has
not been tailored to fit his body this
whole dress this is what it is i've told
him to his face before to get that [ __ ]
done i've even put it in the comments in
his previous instagram post dude it
looks so terrible and so
i was fed up and i was like you know
what the internet has to deal with him
oh man and i guarantee you his next post
he's gonna have a suit that doesn't move
past his heels by seven inches when i
saw that story the first thing i said to
myself is oh no
this fool
literally looks like he could have been
a 2000 nba draft
2000 nba draft suit yeah it was pretty
bad dude it was pretty bad i'm not gonna
lie one of my friends this fool cracked
me the [ __ ] up he said that this fool
looks like a public defender
it's not so accurate
that is so [ __ ] accurate oh my gosh
and then my other friend said he's like
you know he's like my other friend you
know sophia sophia was like he was like
he doesn't not only does he look like a
public defender he looks like a public
defender that if you did the crime you
know you're going to lose
oh man
not even a public defender but a shitty
public defender look and i [ __ ] love
you man i'm just trying to help you out
bro
we are in [ __ ] what what here are we
20 20. oh my god man yeah that was like
year 2000 nba draft suit oh that roast
that's just i was just like oh no
that fool literally raided steve
harvey's closet
oh my god dude
oh yeah it was but it looked pretty bad
i was like dude come on man god damn
dude
if that [ __ ] had pin stripes in it this
fool would have six [ __ ]
yeah it's like you can't be doing that
at not only because it's 20 22 but just
your age now man you know you gotta you
gotta get a properly fitting suit and if
you can't get that [ __ ] tailored before
we continue this podcast this podcast is
brought to you by babble my friends yes
they've been a long time sponsor and if
you can do me a favor click the link and
check it out because if you want to
learn a language in the right way and
super easy you have to get on babel
babel's 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go other language learning apps use
ai for the lesson plans but babel
lessons were created by over 100
language experts do not get gypped you
need to get quality [ __ ] and that's
where babel steps in with babel you can
choose from 14 different languages
including spanish french italian and
german my friends
my friends there are so many ways to
learn with babble in addition to lessons
you can access uh podcast games video
stories and even live classes plus it
comes with a 20 day money back guarantee
you have to understand something not all
language learning apps are the same my
friends and i [ __ ] with babble heavy
because it's dope uh right now you can
save up to 60 off your subscription when
you go to babel.comgb that's battle as
in babble.com
gb for up to 60 off your subscription
babble language for life it doesn't cost
that much bro man
i didn't even point out the the sleeves
honestly oh was it like is it past this
like hey you ever see those emo girls
that have the hoodie with the [ __ ]
thumbs through it yeah that's what that
[ __ ] looked like that [ __ ] was killing
me because i used to sell suits for a
living yeah yeah so looking at that [ __ ]
broke my heart every time this
[ __ ] told me too
i said
i was in a rush to go out i was like bro
i seen you wear that suit like seven
times unless you were in a rush to go
out all those times i don't want to hear
it fix your [ __ ] suit
what the [ __ ] are we talking about
as soon as you said the name i was
trying because that's the first image
that popped into my head for some reason
i was like trying not to laugh i was
like i can't i can't hold on to this man
i only did it because i care man why
she's gonna come up and slap me
that's what i was gonna say right i was
like yo bro it's just slap worthy roast
you put this dude on blast you could
have told them in private again
again
again you know but nah i did it like too
many times you made a [ __ ] psa out of
this and we're helping one person at a
time uh hey for the other people
listening to psa for you guys man don't
don't be wearing outfitting suits my
man's a dope ass [ __ ] real estate
agent but i'll tell you this i wouldn't
have known for the suit
oh man public defender
looks like a public defender
damn dude i i've never thought i would
hear a roast by saying somebody looks
like a public defender man oh my
goodness
you go to jail not our boy in the kill
though nikhil is a sharp looking public
defender
he's trying to change the he's a winning
public defender that's why he's the one
that walks through the door you're like
i'm gonna win today that's my man right
there you see that [ __ ] answer you're
like what is it what is this what is uh
dark brown briefcase
is it it's all tattered as [ __ ]
it's so specific man it's so specific uh
people were cracking me up because it
wasn't me that was roasted i was getting
dms from other people yeah they had all
these jokes well you [ __ ] handed the
roast on a silver platter bro you said
here you go
low-bearing fruit right here low-hanging
fruit right here hey i love him i'm
trying to help him dude
that's how i helped that's what was his
response
huh what's his response he said that he
was rushing out of the house oh that's
what he said i was like you're not
questioning out of the house at all bro
he was trying to help me help us like my
property out in big bear like you wore
that same suit you weren't rushing out
for [ __ ] oh man are you rushing out of
the house gonna sell homes and to go to
a b-boy jam
oh [ __ ] oh my god that was like a
[ __ ] 10 minute detour for the
conversation what the [ __ ] would i say
oh yeah yeah so we were supposed to go
to the smoking group and our buddy
anthony uh he's a different anthony
kendrick's oh so it wasn't even this
though okay but i had to go on that
detour okay
i thought it was him so okay we found
this even worse that it wasn't even the
same thing so we go to the smoking
groups concert yeah and as i'm there i'm
with two girls one home girl and the
other girl i didn't know okay
i don't mind being around drunk people
when i'm drunk yeah right or if you're
not a sloppy drunk if you're a fun drunk
whatever that's all good with me
i didn't realize how drunk they were
because we were all drinking
and so by the time i got to the concert
we had to walk like a mile in because it
was just packed
i didn't realize how smashed these
[ __ ] were until we were walking
yeah and they couldn't [ __ ] keep
themselves together
but i was already kind of sobering up
because they had a beer garden there so
i was just gonna have a couple of beers
and just i'd like to keep myself at a
decent buzz but i'd never like to get
smashed like that
lo and behold i'm getting kind of
irritated because i'm looking for barton
geo in all of them
and i see geo in the distance i see her
[ __ ] blonde hair right which by the
way geo looks like a island boy now
i saw her i already told her that by the
way i could say that i could say that
too because she's my family she's going
to slap me out too
island
yeah so she uh i see her from a dis i'm
about to say what's up
not my friend but her friend who i don't
even [ __ ] know
she's already annoying me because she's
drunk as [ __ ] yaks on my shoe oh no
oh my god
[ __ ] yeah by the way this is my first
festival music festival i've been to in
like eight years nine years uh but are
we talking you caught residues of the
yak or she straight up just yacked on
your shoes straight up yakked almost oh
my god
i'm [ __ ] pissed yeah i don't know who
the [ __ ] she is yeah i literally don't
know who the [ __ ] she is dude i think i
would have had a knee-jerk reaction to
kick her in the face like the moment it
happened you know and i'm like okay yeah
whatever and she's apollo i'm so sorry
i'm zoned
you know just like don't say sorry
whatever you're drunk that's fine just
sober up
and then my other friend
i'm already like yo your friend just
[ __ ] yacked on my shoe i'm not having
a good time at all i'm just trying to
see uh janae aiko i'm trying to see
[ __ ] uh miguel and nas these are the
people i went there to see heidi's
coyote and then also quest love
[ __ ] lo and behold the other girl
throws up on me
i get thrown up on twice where
uh she like missed me and got my shirt
oh my god i'm [ __ ] angry right now as
you should be i spent 300 and like 20
bucks on these tickets yeah
right
i have to now take first of all is at an
open like festival these are two small
little asian girls yeah i can't just
walk because i'm mad walk away and
[ __ ] lead them they're drunk as [ __ ]
right so instead of getting to enjoy
this [ __ ] i had to babysit them because
they were so [ __ ] plastered where
were their friends at it was just them
too they were they were uh so they
bought tickets to go to come to la hang
out do the birthday party and at the
same time go to the smoking groups
concert yeah and so i was like oh i'm
going to we'll just roll together and i
just get yacked on twice
and you know what happens when i see
throw up
yeah makes me want to throw up yeah so
literally this girl yacks on me and i'm
like
you know so she started gagging it's
it's it's three asian people
let's just try evie we're all just
understand so she throws up on my shoe
and that already i can already smell it
yeah
and it's all like bile and gut fluid
because it's all just liquor and alcohol
yeah i'm like whatever and i'm already
yeah
then when the girl [ __ ] projectile
vomits and i dodge it it gets my shirt i
get a whiff i go
i can imagine and i just lost geo i
couldn't see your island boy head
anymore so i couldn't i don't know where
the [ __ ] she was so at that point i was
like [ __ ] it i'm not gonna see these
guys i'm just gonna have to take care of
these people so for the rest of it i was
just taking care of two drugs why is it
human nature to [ __ ] turn to somebody
when they got a yak i don't know why
what i've been [ __ ] yacked on in
class when i was in first grade i'm just
sitting there minding my business and
this [ __ ] [ __ ] got food poisoning or
something she turns to me to [ __ ]
yeah i caught the full thing bro
from [ __ ] my chin down she [ __ ]
just
what did she eat i don't i don't [ __ ]
know man i was worried
i know i was wearing a [ __ ] mickey
mouse sweatsuit though
and she [ __ ] ruined it bro i was
walking to the office with yak dripping
off of me you know that feeling when you
when you [ __ ] like you can't even
take the shirt off because it's exactly
exactly you gotta cut that [ __ ] the
smell i remember this even though i was
[ __ ] like seven eight years old i
still remember this [ __ ] as clear
because traumatizing as [ __ ] you know
but why couldn't she just yak forward or
turn around and why was it
i got a yak
like why do you gotta turn but people do
that [ __ ] all the time they turn to
somebody to [ __ ] yak is it like this
uh i don't know like something in us
where it's like crying for help without
being able to actually say help me dude
drunk
drunk throw up is the worst hell yeah
that's the [ __ ] worst man yeah we
should talk about this though since it's
already connected yeah but it's been a
while but we've been watching this case
unfold so if you guys watch mma
oh yeah jorge mas vidal
and colby covington
got into a [ __ ] scrap fest at a
steakhouse out in miami so just to
preface this uh jorge masvidal one of my
personal favorite welterweights and he
wasn't always a welterweight yeah um for
a very long time because i used to watch
him do backyard fighting with like kimbo
slices yeah yeah back in the days yeah
yeah
i had watched them without even knowing
i had watched them because i remember i
used to watch the kimbo slice fights
right so i saw the fight that he did as
well i just didn't know who the [ __ ] he
was at the time
and then yeah once he started getting
big i was like oh [ __ ] i remember this
dude yeah so jorge masvedal
um
long story short with him if you don't
know who jorge is the guy literally
reinvented himself went on to this
reality tv show this mexican reality tv
show had some time to think to himself
and he came back a better beast he
started knocking people out started
knocked out darren till at that point
had never been knocked out
[ __ ] uh flying knee kale's ben askren
within the which now he has the fastest
knockout in the ufc
pretty [ __ ] crazy what he was doing
yeah now he worked himself up to two
title fights against kamar usman well
colby covington and um colby cummington
and jorge masseval used to be uh
training partners yeah and close friends
as a result exactly so they used to have
uh same coach everything else yeah um
colby covington's stick right now is to
piss people off to get fights and make a
lot of money playing the heel like the
wwe heel yes
and i think what a lot of people have
said at the gym and by the way the coach
that i'm talking about i'm [ __ ]
blinking on the name right now i don't
want to look up look it up but you guys
can um
people in the gym said oh he used to
write colby covington's lines and kobe
covington says some like salacious [ __ ]
right
you know he does say everything to
incite anger like he'll attack people's
family he'll attack your wife or
whatever religion your country country
it doesn't [ __ ] matter yeah kobe
covington and jorge monsvado split right
there's this whole backstory
they use i mean i'm talking about their
friendship was kind of freaking
corny yeah yeah eff's maybe yeah like
literally there's a clip of kobe mazza
uh kobe masada
she's got a cool name yeah so colby
covington as jorge won his fight this is
my best friend yeah we're gonna take
over the world like you're [ __ ]
stupid but that's how corny he is in
real life yeah yeah
yeah and you could tell by his
interviews and everything else and for
me i personally don't care about the
talk i just like that he's a really dope
fighter yes which is why i like kobe
right and his cardio is [ __ ] insane
yeah so i kind of can separate the
fighter from all that other [ __ ]
well
the thing is with jorge maskel there's
actually real beef he actually really
dislikes kobe because of whatever past
drama that they had so up into this
fight there was a lot of [ __ ] talking uh
maz vidal loses he gets outworked yeah
well in these interviews colby covington
he stated himself right while he's on
the mic and i don't know if it's his
character if he's just saying stuff but
he goes whether we're out in a in the
streets in a restaurant
in a parking lot it's on site i'ma
[ __ ] kill this you said that about
dustin poirier too that would be on-site
if you ever saw him yeah so
guess what
be careful what you say or careful what
you wish for because you know what
stupid games get stupid prizes right and
that's exactly what happened hori mas
vidal had a mask on the hoodie on saw
him at the steak house and lit this
month oh no he got he got snitched out
by one of the milk boys because the nut
boys posted a story about it that's how
horry mazvadol found out where he was at
and probably people hit up horry mo yo
hey this dude's slipping he's over at so
and so and then hilary masala went over
there roll up on him sucker punched him
apparently like a couple times chipped
his tooth shift his tooth yeah and then
colby covington ran away yeah called the
cops
so this is like evidently what and press
charges and press charges
so here's the thing
there's a big difference between what
you do on stage and what you do outside
yeah and a lot of people too it's back
and forth some people are like hey if
you ain't about that life don't say that
[ __ ] they go oh he's only doing it for
the promotion i'm all about free speech
and promoting [ __ ] however the [ __ ] you
want but once again i'm also big on you
reap what you sow yeah you got to be
ready for the repercussions yeah so in
colby covington's mind so you put up
this idea that nothing was going to
happen to you just because it's
promotion that is a stippling
stipulation that you discuss with
yourself
it wasn't a great nobody agreed to
nothing exactly so it's kind of pure
nonsense and people are like he's a
professional athlete he should know
better in the octagon
but outside of it it's a it's a
different story well the the fundamental
difference here is you're dealing with
um a wholesome all-american wrestling
kid versus a street kid exactly that's
the fundamental difference jory moswell
takes it one way colby thinks it's just
entertainment that's what it is at the
end of the day once we leave that cage
in that arena
it's it's all good but clearly
they're receiving it very differently
and the other thing about that too which
i don't understand is that you know
obviously colby covington fans are going
to feel a certain way they go that's
completely unprofessional well so is his
[ __ ] talking
that's that's that wasn't the part of
the quote-unquote script that any ufc
fighter took and they he took it upon
himself to say you know call him um
what's it called fidel castro
when jorge's family literally escaped
communism his aunt got a tip blown off
from a mind yeah like there's some [ __ ]
that has gone through his [ __ ] family
you know
calling him a deadbeat dad which people
like he didn't talk about his kids
directly yeah he called him a deadbeat
desert he's not around for his children
that's talking about his family don't
let let's not [ __ ] go fall into
semantics don't be [ __ ] stupid he did
talk about his family so
i'm not really i'm like i said i don't
know what i would do in those type of
situations i'm just saying you reap what
you sow yeah you go out you say i catch
you anywhere slipping i see you out in
these streets i'll [ __ ] kill you yeah
you put that out in the ether so what
the [ __ ] i don't understand why people
people are acting and one of the
funniest quotes i saw on twitter was
people are acting that acting as if cope
as if jorge masavado sucks uh steven
wonderboy thompson
you know
it's kobe covington yeah exactly you
know and wonder boy is the nicest guy in
the world
it's it's they act as if he didn't say
these words they go it was just him
promoting stuff it doesn't [ __ ]
matter because nobody was giving a habib
type this type of [ __ ] yeah
habib
literally and conor was like it's you
know it's all just a job but habibi beat
the [ __ ] out of him and then he jumped
out of the cage trying to [ __ ] up dylan
dennis there's a lot of stuff here
that's what but that's what i'm saying
going back to the whole will smith and
chris rockshit it depends who's the one
doing it right yes yes yes and in this
case jorge took a major [ __ ] l from
this chris brown yeah i've never seen
somebody who's like pretty universally
beloved in the mma community become a
dark horse so fast you know i was like
holy [ __ ] bro like you [ __ ] ruined
your career with this move i mean people
are split some people are like hey
yeah i definitely yeah i definitely saw
those comments where it's like what
you're saying right now the sentiment of
like hey you talk that [ __ ] you better
be ready to back it up anywhere and
everywhere just like you said right but
you know there are the other people i
think who
look at it from a more
cookie cutter like
yeah bobby comington though said the
funniest [ __ ] line he got interviewed
in a podcast recently i believe where he
was asked about it and he goes i didn't
get dropped i just took a knee for the
first responders
yeah and he also
he also said he donated the two things
that i didn't [ __ ] my tooth i donated it
to the first responders so [ __ ] dumb
dude but you know colby definitely did
do a good job of making people pay
attention to him i mean like he he he's
playing the heel roll really well and
obviously people who've known him
personally like even in the wrestling
community your chael sonnens your dc's
right they know that that's not who he
is in real life but that's the thing
like for a moment too i was questioning
whether or not this jorge mazvadol and
colby covington beef was real like
because it was completely possible in my
mind that they could have
planned this together like hey let's
both [ __ ] you know get our bread make
this paper by creating this feud between
us and drawing attention right i saw
that as a plausible situation
but then after the fight when there was
clearly still animosity i was like okay
i guess this [ __ ] is pretty real between
them yeah i mean
there's definitely something that went
awry between them um i mean they've
talked about their own piece you know
the weird thing is the people that have
trained with kobe though they don't say
nice things about them right people
people who say nice things about kobe
are people who have met him in small
glimpses yeah that's the problem that i
have so
joy rogan too joe rogan is saying some
weird [ __ ] he goes i met kobe he's the
sweetest guy ever joe you met him
in your like
like
in the quick glimpse you've never sat
down with them shared in meals you've
been in and out with them in a training
room
and you know people see him interact
with fans look how sweet he is
you don't everybody who has been around
him and i've only realized this recently
is that the people that have been around
him that have sweat blood and tears
around him are the ones that dislike him
yeah people in this close inner circle
so if everybody is inner circle say the
same thing about him yeah but people who
only met him in an instance that's
that's a true tell like true sign there
yeah well i mean but here's the thing is
that like guys like dc and chael uh who
you know are very uh
i guess intimate with the wrestling
community too and and they they know
they've known who colby covington is as
he was coming up
it seemed like they're always alluding
to the fact that this not what you're
seeing is not who colby covington
actually is but you're right there are
these other people in the mma community
who've said you know jon jones included
i don't i mean you got to take jon jones
with a grain of salt because he's just
come back himself or if a scumbag like
jon jones says right right there's that
argument too he's a piece of [ __ ] like i
hate like i don't even know this dude
and he says we're best friends
yeah that's the weird thing too right
and
um it was said too that his coach was
like writing him his lines and every and
the story that i've heard from multiple
people that have trained with him is
that originally it was a bit
and then the bit started becoming real
and it started becoming a part of his
personality and there was no stopping
that happening i could see that it kind
of got to his head a little bit yeah so
you know at the end of the day like for
me like i said i don't really know the
guy too this is all conjecture at this
point
i'm saying the boy got the two-piece in
the soda and um hey talk that [ __ ] yeah
that's what happens yeah the octagon and
what happens outside are two separate
[ __ ] things
you can't i mean you can go around
saying that [ __ ] but you can't be
surprised when you have to pay for it
that's just the thing i don't understand
they go but that's what the internet is
now it's like no we get to say whatever
it's a they go this is this is what they
go it's a free country it's free speech
yes free speech you can say what you
want it doesn't mean you're free of
consequences
that is that what is nonsense that's the
part people always forget you know yeah
i could walk around i had to explain to
this kid on twitter he goes oh so you
believe in free speech and you know
freedom and stuff but you block people
on your personal page that you know say
offensive stuff to you yeah i was like
yeah i believe in free speech but do it
somewhere else this is you know what
this is this is the communist country of
sylvania
i dictate what the [ __ ] i want to hear
and say yeah you you just walk into
czechoslovania yeah all right and guess
what i'm the dictator i'm putin
back bad timing
too soon bad timing that was that was
actually in poor taste i
you reject that statement
you're kim jong-un
that was something else man i thought
that [ __ ] was fake for sure when you
sexted me i thought that was fake so he
has like a missile and he does the
slo-mo [ __ ] mission impossible
with the music playing in the background
and the [ __ ] doors opening in the
hangar dog so i was watching this into
this joe rogan podcast yeah and
kim jong-il
was uh i forgot who he i think ali sadiq
is who uh was on the rogan podcast and
he was talking about how
kim jong-il has these transcripts of the
amazing things that he's done and kim
jong-il in writing said the day that he
was born all the birds in north korea
started speaking increasingly
yeah the the stories out of there like
that the [ __ ]
he invented the burrito in 2000 i mean
you know they're talking you know
they're considered gods right
kimirisong uh kim jong-ir
and
kim jong-un right they're all
supposed to be gods
that's that's how they paint the picture
of themselves and the people and then
they indoctrinate the people with that
idea and with these crazy stories that
you're talking about
and then you even if you don't believe
it you have to act like you do
but why the burrito
the burrito has been around way before
2011. i clearly know that taco bell has
been around way before 2011. it's it's
their i guess little dig at [ __ ]
saying hey you know we gave the western
culture this you know it's hilarious
yeah he's like write this on a piece of
paper
i make a burrito forever
yeah like something that has been around
for probably i don't know like 70 80
years 100 years maybe even longer maybe
even longer man how long has the
tortilla been around yeah god damn yeah
and it's mexican food how would you have
made the burrito
that's what i'm saying man
they uh when it comes to
what they're capable of and what they've
done there's no boundaries man they've
done everything and anything that's the
most [ __ ] ridiculous [ __ ] i've ever
heard of my life ridiculous i have a
number one longest penis in all of the
world but that whole like [ __ ]
mythology that they've created for
themselves is these gods it is
ridiculous i mean you look into it and
yeah what they're claiming they've done
i think like uh they're saying uh
correct me if i'm wrong here for people
who are watching but i'm pretty sure
there was um
an idea that uh they don't even [ __ ]
yeah that they're too holy to even [ __ ]
yeah so kim jong-il yeah or kim his son
was like
i never take a picture yeah something
like that if you hear a part yeah that's
not me yeah so i never pause yeah no
[ __ ] no [ __ ] like they're too holy you
know they're they're they're like too
high of a being to even do something
like jesus christ
like dog you don't got a [ __ ]
butthole i'm sorry
what what do you got back there then i
want to see this fool literally go to a
crowd pull down his pants
open up his seat barbie that is just
flesh yeah there's no phone not even a
crack it's just no it's just a mound
yeah why
that's hilarious yeah i'm pretty sure
that that's uh one of the
whole ideas about them as a god you know
that they don't even [ __ ] that they're
they're you know that's too human apple
has better looking suits than that
[Laughter]
what why you gotta drag him into the
seat
oh my god that's my guy dude
the [ __ ] up thing about that that
comparison right now is they get their
[ __ ] tailored and it still looks [ __ ]
terrible and you said they still got it
better than
hey if you guys ever need
the guy knows what he's [ __ ] doing
don't judge a man by his suit and judge
him by the way well apparently people
aren't judging a man
they said it's feeling like a public a
losing public defender man
basically calling him a [ __ ] loser in
life no they're not saying everybody
loves and there's nobody that hates that
fool he's he's [ __ ] sweet as [ __ ]
yeah no i don't dude i i'm not saying
anything poor about the dude all i'm
saying is when you posted it i was like
oh no
there is a disclaimer when you become a
good friend of mine oh my god well guys
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast you can catch the genius
brains every sunday at 12 p.m you can
see at ed2 and check out secret society
we have our spring summer launch coming
real soon oh it's gonna be so sick and
if you [ __ ] love the back to basics
line that we just re-upped on you'll
love the spring slash summer [ __ ] and
remember like i said we about our [ __ ]
is going to be [ __ ] dope so
everything is upgraded let's just put it
that way okay yeah
i love it yeah uh you can catch ed to us
s-c-r-t-s-o-c-i-e-t-y
uh check it out uh genius brains if you
guys see us give us a five stars like
and comment in the videos and all the
[ __ ] reviews and [ __ ] and we will see
you all next time peace